and if that occurs and given what I is
just did do you think Isis one of or the
most important company encrypt it right
now I do and and it's a double-edged
sword
I've been positive about them in the in
the conversation here that we've
recorded so far but as you know as we
were chatting earlier there there there
are definitely a lot of downsides to the
way that Wall Street is going to
approach coin what's the biggest fear
there well they're gonna rehypothecation
and they're going to create more claims
to Bitcoin than actually exist and it's
so fascinating then you know then the
seventeen million bitcoins that exist
it's so fascinating to talk to both the
Y the Wall Street folks as well as the
crypto folks in folks understanding what
that really means I think a lot of my
Wall Street compatriots don't understand
that that's a big part rehypothecation
is a big part of how Wall Street makes
money it creates more paper claims than
there are actual assets so the dole food
cases is Exhibit A for that forty nine
point two million brokerage statements
saying that that the folks owned dole
food shares but there were really only
thirty-six point seven million shares
outstanding and all forty-nine point two
million brokerage statements were valid
that was a Delaware court case how did
the financial system create one-third
more claims to dole food shares than
there were real dole food shares it's
the it's the market for pledged
collateral it's it's all the securities
lending reification and and the like
that that takes place on Wall Street
where the accounting systems lose track
of who really owns what and basically
turning those assets in to io u--'s if
if you actually owned the real dole food
shares you would never have had anything
like that happen yep if you own the real
Bitcoin you will never have anything
like that happen but Wall Street's that
is a big part of their business model
they what they want to inter mediate
trades and so if they can inflate the
number of underlying assets they inter
mate inter mediate more trades and a lot
of folks have been shocked on the crypto
side to here this is how Wall Street
works and interestingly there's been
some Wall Street people who stood up in
the in the crypto in the Twitter debates
and said and defended this
and I that is absolutely a rational
position there defending it as this is
what brings liquidity to markets this is
what greases the skids of trading and
this is what's going to bring liquidity
to Bitcoin and a very respected person
actually said to me that this
I won't identify folks just just because
these are not personal debates their
substantive debates and I don't want to
personalize it but said to me that Wall
Street is is going to fix the
quote-unquote problem that that Bitcoin
has which is that it is limited to 21
million coins and that scarcity is its
quote unquote problem and that is that
is absolutely how Wall Street thinks
about it but the crypto folks obviously
knows like know that but they love the
scarcity exactly that's listening to and
reading the quotes from the CEO of vice
talking about needing to centralize
Bitcoin talking about needing to bring
trust and transparency to Bitcoin these
are just antithetical to Bitcoin and the
crypto folks are you know lumber a
number of people use the word word
cringeworthy when hearing them talk
about this but the Wall Street folks
read that and say well exactly there's
such a misunderstanding between the two
but it is not just a communication
misunderstanding it is a deep
philosophical difference